[Music]
on this saturday night expiration date
canada's covid19 support benefits are
set to expire what it means for
businesses and workers they're the only
reason why i'm open without those we we
would not survive evacuation complete
ukraine says all civilians have finally
escaped the steel plant in mariupol as
the country braces for a renewed russian
assault
forced to cover up the taliban sparks
international outcry by ordering all
afghan women to be covered head to toe
plus birthday reunion
[Applause]
[Music]
a mother and daughter separated by war
reunite for the first time in 80 years
global national
reporting tonight
jeff semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us they were a lifeline for countless
canadians during the pandemic but after
today canada's remaining covid19
emergency benefits are set to expire
these are some of the programs ending
this weekend topping the list canadians
who can't work because they or a family
member have a positive test will no
longer be eligible for government
support neither will businesses that
were hit hard and had received help
paying their employees
those benefits lasted two years and cost
hundreds of billions of dollars the
federal government points to canada's
record low unemployment as evidence the
programs are no longer needed abigail
beeman reports on the changes and
reaction from businesses
the owner of this ottawa restaurant gets
cancellations because someone in a party
is sick every single day add in people
not yet comfortable dining indoors
staffing challenges and rising costs
with every new wave or new variant
there's a lot of
uncertainty because they're telling
everybody they should stay home and only
go out if they need to yet we're
expected to be open fully and
and run a normal business summer baird
hopes patio season will mean breaking
even but she's been relying on federal
pandemic supports saturday is the last
day for new money businesses can still
apply retroactively they're the only
reason why i'm open
still because without those we we would
not survive it is premature to eliminate
all of the major support programs the
canadian federation of independent
business is calling for more loan
forgiveness from the feds customers have
not returned in the same volume that
were there pre-pandemic for so many
sectors of the economy the finance
minister's office points to canada's
best unemployment rate in five decades
and the gdp as indicators of a strong
economy the time for extraordinary
coveted support
is over it's not like you can just go
and you know pick another business off
the tree
this advisor says more attention needs
to be spent learning what businesses are
actually dealing with the real world
challenges of implementation at the
ground level with supply and staffing
issues what can we do to try to
you know within reason maintain these
businesses
because once they're gone they're gone
this week canada's top doctors said
hospitalization rates are starting to
decline along with case counts and
positivity rates hopeful news with
warmer weather on the way as businesses
hope more customers will follow abigail
beeman global news ottawa
more severe weather is on its way to
parts of manitoba even as hundreds are
still recovering from major flooding
last week that province says more than
60 millimeters of rain is expected in
some of the hardest hit areas over the
next week along with wind gusts of up to
80 kilometers an hour officials say the
heavy rain could see water levels rise
by as much as 15 centimeters in some
already flooded areas environment canada
has also issued a severe thunderstorm
watches for a wide area along the
saskatchewan border the weather service
says there's a risk of large hail heavy
rain and even a tornado watch in the
region
to some rare good news now from ukraine
that country's deputy prime minister
says that all women children and seniors
have now been evacuated from a steel
mill in mariupol the plant has been
under siege for weeks and remains the
last ukrainian outpost in the strategic
port city as reggie shakini reports
russian forces are working to complete
their conquest of mariupol in time for
victory day celebrations
called back to be put on display russian
soldiers rehearsed for victory day the
may 9th anniversary marks russia's
triumph over nazi germany in the second
world war
the day is celebrated across europe
but this year it carries new
significance moscow will look to
highlight victories in ukraine despite
achieving very little
leaving ukraine's president to issue a
warning to obey curfews and air raid
sirens with fear russia could increase
its attacks
those worries a reality on saturday with
strikes in the southern port city of
odessa and across the east
the ground started crumbling the roof
was shaking says this donetsk resident
this is rebel-controlled territory
the enemy is carrying out artillery
shelling and air assaults to strike
positions of our troops says a
spokesperson for ukraine's armed forces
on friday u.s president joe biden
committed to another 150 million dollars
in aid a move rattling russia's nerves
leading to more veiled threats against
the west
and while ukraine's president is eager
for a diplomatic end he says russia
doesn't appear to be willing to engage
but for so many the end came weeks ago
it's a shame to look at this i lived
here for 40 years
72 year old zenita baranchuk lost
everything on march 24th she now lives
in this trailer beside the remains of
her home
i never thought the russian brothers
would attack us and do something like
this with my ukraine she says
meanwhile after a phone call on friday
to underscore a joint commitment in
holding russia accountable both
president biden and prime minister
justin trudeau will join their g7
counterparts for a video conference on
sunday with the invitation extended to
ukraine's president where sanctions are
expected to be on the agenda
jeff reggie zucchini in washington
thanks reggie ukrainians are relying
heavily on foreign donations to repel
that russian invasion the country has
received weapons protective equipment
and medicine and ukrainians themselves
are also providing supplies and
transporting them across the country to
people most in need as crystal comancing
reports those volunteers are proving to
be a critical link in the conflict
so we need this
equipment from gas masks to blankets and
everything in between
ukrainian volunteers have created their
own supply chains and delivery networks
to support the war efforts it's
necessary for me for
my family for my country because i'm
afraid for
our
life global news was invited into one of
the group's warehouses in the capital
and witnessed a bustling operation
we distribute to refugees who are in
kiev who come from all over ukraine from
those cities where hostilities are
taking place in peace time supplies for
vulnerable people were collected here
now in a time of war
everyone is vulnerable
supplies are most needed in areas cut
off or under attack volunteers work with
partners to select priority items find
the safest times to travel and which
routes to take
deliveries have also been timed with
rescues the volunteer network has been
repeatedly contacted by people
looking for safe passage
we got a lot of
phone calls from our friends from
people that we
don't know
and some letters messengers
in facebook please help us over the past
two months they have driven supplies
into bucha
kramatorsk and driven out women and
children
often under dangerous conditions sure
scared because
it's dangerous we understand it but
we don't have any
way
we need to support each other
a few hours away in chernihev protective
vests make their way to those who need
them the liberated city is quiet now but
in march it was completely encircled and
there were fears it would fall
the vote itself is not over when it is
quiet in the city something inside me
motivates me to do more and to continue
to do what i am doing
a chain of like-minded people united by
a sense of duty convinced victory and
peace will come
crystal gomson global news
keith
turning now to the desperate search for
survivors in havana after yesterday's
explosion at a high end hotel
officials there say at least 26 people
were killed including four children and
a pregnant woman a natural gas leak has
been ruled the cause of the blast at the
96 room hotel it did not have any guests
at the time because it was undergoing
renovations it was scheduled to reopen
this tuesday
afghanistan's taliban rulers have once
again ordered all women to wear
head-to-toe clothing in public
the law is reminiscent of the taliban's
previous rule back in the 1990s the
militant group says male relatives of
women who do not obey will be visited
and could face prison time most afghan
women wear head scarves for religious
reasons but many in cities such as kabul
do not cover their faces the taliban has
faced intense criticism from western
governments for limiting women's rights
including keeping girls high schools
closed despite previous promises to
reform
coming up bad for the brand a former
conservative cabinet minister reacts to
this week's heated party leadership
debate
plus special delivery why this pizza
lover went to great lengths for a slice
retired general jonathan vance has been
stripped of the prestigious order of
military merit the former chief of the
defense staff pleaded guilty in march to
one count of obstruction of justice and
was conditionally discharged from the
military that charge came after
allegations of inappropriate behavior
first published last year by global news
those allegations sparked a national
reckoning over military culture in
canada according to a government notice
vance was stripped of the military honor
at his own request
the federal conservative leadership
candidates will gather this week for the
party's first official debate all six
candidates are expected to be there and
after this week's unofficial debate
descended into a verbal brawl many are
expecting more fireworks our eric
sorensen spoke to former leadership
candidate peter mckay on the west block
so eric what did mckay make of that
debate this week
jeff it wasn't even an official debate
but neither was it just an introductory
skirmish the conservative leadership
candidates came out firing mp pierre
poliev in particular targeted the former
progressive conservative leader and
quebec premier jean chade
the average trucker has more integrity
in his pinky finger than you had in your
entire scandal-plagued liberal cabinet
mr poliev during that period supported
an illegal blockade you cannot make laws
and break laws
leadership debates are by design a forum
for competing visions and tough
exchanges among candidates says one
former leadership hopeful but peter
mckay told us on the west block that the
discussion was at times uncivilized and
that's not good for the conservative
brand
when it becomes personal when you see
some of the you know really pointed kind
of nasty exchanges
on display in that debate i i don't
think it bodes well and i frankly i
don't think the overall public
impression
of canadians is is positive mckay says
one of the challenges will be to choose
a leader who can not only win the
backing of conservatives but can build
broader support across the country to
win the next election let's never lose
sight of that fact it's about
competitiveness in the next general
election i think that conservatives have
to be frankly quite concerned about
three elections a possible fourth
electoral loss
is uh is very hard to swallow for for
members of this party the party plans
two official debates this month the
first one is this wednesday in edmonton
all six candidates are expected to
attend and all eyes will be watching to
see if some candidates ease off on
personal attacks or double down on them
jeff eric sorenson in ottawa thanks eric
and you can watch the full interview
with former conservative cabinet
minister peter mckay on the west block
that's tomorrow right here on global
still ahead export ban why the cost of
cooking oil is going up
you're watching global national
telecom companies rogers and shaw are
vowing to push ahead with their proposed
26 billion dollar merger despite
canada's competition commissioner saying
he intends to block it the companies
issued a joint statement today adding
they will continue to engage with the
competition bureau in an effort to
resolve the issue the crtc has approved
the acquisition under a series of
conditions however it still needs the
green light from the ministry of
innovation science and economic
development
russia's war in ukraine has caused
turmoil on international commodity
markets raising prices at the grocery
store the latest item affected is
cooking oil ukraine makes up nearly half
the world's sunflower oil exports and
with those supplies stalling the price
for other oils has skyrocketed as dan
spector explains a major move by another
player in the global market could have
significant consequences here in canada
going up and down the aisles of your
local grocery store there's no doubt
you're rolling your cart past dozens of
products that contain palm oil cookies
chips hazelnut spread it's a key
ingredient in all of them it's in
almost everything
but an unexpected decision on the other
side of the world will now have
implications across canada
export the indonesian president shocked
commodity traders late last month when
he announced his country was halting
palm oil exports indonesia is the
world's biggest producer accounting for
more than half of global supply but as
the war in ukraine contributes to rising
food prices elsewhere indonesia went
insular taking the unprecedented step to
keep the cost of cooking oil more
affordable for its 275 million people
there is no other oil readily available
palm is the major oil in world trade the
halt in exporting comes as other
vegetable oils face shortages including
sunflower and rapeseed out of ukraine
and russia canadian canola is down too
due to last year's disastrous prairie
drought that will put not only
pressure on the price of palm oil but it
also put pressure on any other vegetable
oils out there really including olive
oil palm oil production has long been
considered environmentally harmful its
mass producers in indonesia and beyond
bulldoze and burn rainforest to make way
for plantations
borneo has lost roughly 150 000
orangutans in the past 16 years alone
greenpeace does not see the export ban
as a reprieve for wildlife but hopes
it's a time for consumers to reflect on
what makes up our favorite food items
and many cosmetic products while palm
oil can be produced sustainably a lot of
it isn't and as prices of all cooking
oils rise so will our grocery bills
sylvain charlevois says this will only
exacerbate food shortage issues globally
poor countries
which can't really store calories will
be hit first the hope is that with good
weather canadian canola producers can
return to normal this season but with no
end in sight for the palm oil export ban
no single country can fill the gap dan
specter global news montreal
up next how this woman celebrated her
98th birthday with a very special guest
welcome back at 98 years old gerda cole
thought she'd never see the daughter she
gave up for adoption eight decades ago
but today her birthday wish was granted
he that fear
i don't know
a miracle it is a miracle
did you think this morning i can't think
of it any other way
the woman next to her 80 year old sonja
grist who tracked down her birth mother
to toronto while researching her family
history during the pandemic she
eventually planned a reunion to meet her
mother on her 98th birthday their story
dates all the way back to 1939 when cole
was sent to england to escape
persecution of the jewish population in
vienna she gave her newborn daughter up
for adoption in 1942 grit has stayed in
england ever since but cole moved all
over the world eventually settling here
in canada safe to say this is a birthday
neither of them will ever forget
well how far would you go for your
favorite slice of pizza as kylie stanton
explains one ontario-born man who now
lives in bc went to extreme lengths for
a taste of home
the oven heats up the pizza goes in
and the countdown is on i wish we had
smell-o-vision because that's half of
the experience john palmer has waited
years for this moment what's another 30
minutes i grew up in windsor and i
always had fond memories of my childhood
this pizza is one of them and it turns
out he's not alone
nigel and i talked about it
you know on the periphery for years yes
it was fantastic but to talk is one
thing the sauce the cheese pepperoni
canned mushrooms to taste is another i
finally stomped my foot and said we're
going to make this happen i said yeah
let's go for it palmer picked the spot
antonino's original pizza and placed the
order and they arranged to half bake the
pizza
wrap it put it in the freezer when it
was ready for transport he needed a
courier to run it to ups enter my old
high school chum jim jeff's
call him out of the blue after years of
not talking and said how are you by the
way jeffs came through getting the pies
to ups just in time where abdul was
holding his driver while they packaged
everything got it on the truck and got
it in the air that night the next day
after a nearly 4 000 kilometer journey
it was mission accomplished you got to
be real hardcore windsor pizza fans like
john and nigel
to pay 350 dollars to have 10 large
pizzas shipped then at the cost of the
actual pizza 10 pizzas 267 dollars this
was definitely a more of an emotional
decision than a financial decision but
in this moment time to eat worth every
penny and surpassing all expectations oh
even better even better as you'll find
out it's incredible it explains why
these two aren't the first to go to such
lengths for a slice antonino's has
shipped to other parts of canada and the
u.s and has recently received
international requests we actually got a
call saying hey i'm calling from dubai i
want two medium pizzas shipped out here
and i honestly thought it was a joke no
just seriously good pizza where one bite
can take you back in time well done
windsor pizza and thanks for the
memories kathy stanton global news
victoria
making me hungry that is global national
for this saturday night i'm jeff semple
tonight's your canada is midland ontario
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow have a great night
[Music]